so here you
are
Vigilant narrowly
focused how's I don't give a [__]
going what's ultimately interesting to
me about the sequence is neither of
these guys seem to be enjoying
themselves you know and that always
seems to be such an added layer to most
fight scenes in movies is the sheer
sadism that is gifted the proceedings by
the villain and I really like the idea
of beginning in sort of cowardice there
was nothing about this that was you know
the samurai meeting the other Samurai on
the road this was like no I'm going to
sneak up behind you and shoot you in the
back of the head if I can get away with
it and that's what the plan seems to be
until obviously things go
right David definitely was searching for
some kind of an elevated sense of of um
fear that he wanted to get from the
audience and of course he photographed
it completely in the
dark well David said to me he wanted it
dark he said I want this to be a fight
scene that exists almost exclusively in
the dark I said great you know then I I
started to have a little bit of anxiety
actually about about how dark it it was
and whether or not I had gone too
far and David said there are things we
need the audience to see and and then
there are things that they only need to
hear and then there are things that they
can infer we lit the entire scene once
and it was great because we were able to
rehearse things and and shoot it in
sequence that
way he hears the brute taking a shower
he hears the television coming from the
other room and these things Jump Around
in perspective with the picture cuts
that Kirk
created the sound was to to indicate oh
this guy has no idea that he's going to
get ambushed but then then we as the
audience are completely surprised
because it's the other way around in
fact and if you're a garden lover
prepare to be very excited because this
is one of the oldest
country stick to your plan I love the
whole setup of this I love the
stretching of it how slow it
is anticipate don't improvise it's a
great example of what the movie is
killer is in control trust no one it's
steady it's
exacting until it's not fight only the
battle you're paid to
fight really started with Dave momer
stunt fiz Dave momer took the designs of
that set constructed it on an empty
stage floor out of cardboard boxes and
then they choreographed and rehearsed it
over the course of God it must have been
several weeks or months
Maybe the first thing that I did was go
into the dark corners of the internet
and just start watching actual footage
of you know the people caught on street
corners with their iPhones of people
legitimately beating the crap out of
each other the things that would always
make me just react were the big slam I
talked to Don about creating these wild
floors that we could pull out and throw
8 in pads in with high density foone
that had been Scenic to look like the
floor and then put on a Dead Man line so
that his chest would just kiss Justin's
when they would hit the
ground from that moment on it's a popery
of noise and props very specific
articulations of glass not only are we
seeing the Practical props but then all
the beautiful subtle uses of CG that
creates this incredibly anxious intense
sequence I love the TV we discuss this
initially as a way that Justin would be
so backlit that you would never know
that it was him we were having issues
with the power center in the TV when
Justin hit it it would shut the TV off
completely so we had to find TVs where
the power source was off
[Music]
center the beginning of this whole thing
was how do we have a fight that really
looks like hand to hand
combat and then I kind of threw in this
thing at the last minute which was they
got to keep it
quiet The Stunt World the sounds that we
make are a form of communication making
sure that the other guy knows your
Cadence is correct and if his sound
timing is off even if I'm not looking at
him I know I have to adjust there's a
lot of grunting and huffing and puffing
and gugging and you know to me I want
this to be the world's quietest fight
only in so much as that these two guys
didn't want to wake up the neighbors who
would then call the the cops on them and
I was like let's take it all out it's
just going to be bones breaking and
crushing plaster and it was really kind
of disconcerting the first time you saw
it cuz you were like well they don't see
feel like they're hurting each other
it's like well they are hurting each
other and ren has yet to decide whether
or not the audience will will feel
that
[Music]
David really wanted to hear the
difference between the the weight of
these two men Salah is 250 lbs he's just
pure muscle and I want to feel that
house on its Stills creaking and
groaning and then we'd add low
frequencies to Sala so that when he
moved it was like oh my God this guy's a
menace relentlessness and the exhausting
nature of the fight just the brutality
of
it is enjoyable I think more when you
get built-in
paes so that you can hope that it's over
and then go oh [__] it's still
[Music]
[Applause]
happening then when the tables are
turned and the killer grabs the the
poker iron start swishing it then it's a
dangerous sound that he finally
possesses what's really interesting
about how Trent resar and attakus Ross
came up with the music here was that
it's part visceral part panic in a way
almost horror likee almost painful which
is exactly by
Design
beautiful evolving uh hypnotic in a way
Rhythm when we did the first rehearsals
Michael ran around the corner of the
kitchen and then The Gunshot goes off
and Michael said I just feels kind of
stupid that I'm just sitting here I can
I reach into the drawer and and and look
for a weapon and David said yeah that's
fine and you know the drawers on David
sets are always dressed the kitchens are
ostensibly functional kitchens so
Michael reaches in and he pulled out the
cheese grater and he gave that kind of
that amazing face and and David said
okay great take every prop out of that
drawer except for the cheese grater
we're going with it David was like What
if we made it sound like it's a
beautiful knife coming out of the drawer
as if it's going to save him like
something from Lord of the Rings
[Music]
Shing and then he throws it and it's
this the cheapest cheese
gr it was a master plan of let's sh show
everybody the house quietly and then the
fight will go around the house again and
conclude with where you started which
helped with finding the weapon under the
bed we didn't want to cross a line we
didn't want to use really long lenses
and disorient the audience we wanted to
be uh the information to be very clear
geographically I thought that each room
should have a distinct color tone um and
ultimately decided that the the bathroom
should be the brightest there sort of or
in the bathroom and that's of course
where the climax of the scene happens so
uh I like the idea of the bathroom being
the kind of the
beacon and it also gives you a moment to
see this guy is committed to the
destruction of Michael fastfender at
this moment that door opens that's is
going to
die ultimately was the most satisfying
to find his hand coming under the bed
you know most people not showing the
killer until after he shot but you you
could cut that completely differently it
could be the killer raising the hand up
and barring the first shot and then go
there there was a lot of different ways
to trade
that Diva Diva's Incredible Dog we were
having trouble getting D.A to settle
down and and sleep on that pad in the
beginning and we ultimately light R scan
D.A with my iPhone so the wide shot at
the beginning of the sequence is CG Diva
courtesy of my of my
iPhone one of the things that we had to
do as a special effect was go in and
take her tail off because she was so
happy to see Salah every time that was
quite a commitment there was a lot of
stuff with that dog shot through a
chainlink fence so it was no easy task
to remove a waging tail David was
obsessed with Nan he's going to chase
the Killer and I want to hear the
character of the dog when he comes up to
the brute and sees that the brute is
dead I want to feel the dog being
sad and then turns to the you you are
the one that did
this and this whole series of snars
and vure couldn't get enough
Chomp molp cocktail was fun the wick
actually here is
CG the electricians built an LED Wick
that is doing interactive lighting he
got really really close to throwing that
thing through the broken window that's
in the door he's an athlete yeah for
sure I've done that walk at the end of
the day it broke my ribs and separated
my shoulder and didn't want to tell
anybody on set that it had happened and
then got back to the honeywagon and
couldn't take my shirt off cuz I
couldn't lift my arms This Is What It
Takes well you must commit yourself to
[Music]
if you want to
succeed
simple